so if Ben was to get this message and
then and other people like him two times
in the last three years he went to rehab
beautiful about it and I'm not a you
know I struggle with my faith I struggle
with with belief but I do I do see
what's unique about Islam from other
man-made religions how would you explain
it to been in in a minute with
conspiracy theories that may or may not
be true maybe some of those conspiracies
theories are actually true but what are
you gonna do about it is it synthetic is
it man-made is it this I'm concerned
about a world where pharmaceutical
companies can manufacture diseases for
which they are the only ones who have
manufactured a cure you know we hear a
lot of people getting sick because of
the the immune system being compromised
genetically modified foods and the
environment and bad food bad water and
all these things that's it let's look at
this coronavirus situation this lockdown
let's look at it like that yeah for a
lot of people it's uncomfortable yeah
how's everything nice background there
bro how you been how's everything over
there in London UK well I'm now in
London first of all I live in the
countryside far away from London so my
life is hardly different at all to be
honest it's just a lot quieter but where
I live is really quiet anyway to be
honest so you know he you know life's
pretty much the same to be honest we
missed you there and a great trip we saw
Hamza sources was there okay and some of
the rest of the crew of this
organisation you know this guy these
guys they were they were in Bosnia yeah
did he tell you about the trip in Bosnia
yeah I mean I was watching you guys on
you know I think I was I don't know if
it was Instagram or or whatever it was
something I was well between the stories
and you were there with chef hey Tim I
saw that he
they're also and some of the brothers so
I mean I was pretty much you know
keeping pace with it to be honest
through social media
so yeah hamdulillah it seemed really
good yeah they've gone back there a
couple of times as well so that's really
trying to figure out how to get things
going there in in Bosnia because I know
the situation is a little bit complex
and a little bit difficult but you know
they're trying to do some stuff trying
to do some work in Charlotte yes so how
is the situation now as far as in your
area so you're not in the big city by
London my your you're in the board look
down so I mean it's like you're in
lockdown there also we've all got the
same rules to follow
actually my area has quite an aging
population so I think people are you
know particularly being careful here so
you're only allowed to go in the
supermarkets you know everyone has to
keep you know like 6 feet apart they
only let people in in the supermarkets
and very limited numbers but things have
calmed down the panic buying seems to
have stopped
you know the shops are stocked up it's
just very quiet you know we can't really
go anywhere we can't drive anywhere so
you know from that perspective you know
I you people can still go to work if
they have to the government hasn't
actually I don't know like work can
still happen but basically shops are
more closed but I mean a lot of I mean I
era we've closed our offices anyway and
everyone's working from home so what are
your overall thoughts I mean to this
global pandemic that's happening what
goes to your mind what do you what do
you guys what are you thinking analyzing
everything
I don't know Roy I think it's it's I
think it's it's a big wake-up call from
a lot you know I think what really is is
to make everybody realize that I think
there's a few really I mean for me I
always try to look for the positive
things I don't I fight because the
province said you know like how
wonderful is the situation of the
everything that happens to them is good
you know so for us Muslims everything is
good if some Barca comes to us some
blessing you know we're thankful and
that's good for us and if some test or
trial comes you know we're patient and
that's good for us
so I always look for the good in things
I don't you know there's a nice saying
the obstacle is the way so when
something like this happens I'm always
trying to look for okay what's the
positives and they're actually so many
positives I mean I'm one of the I'm very
very a person who for a long time in my
life but especially more now I'm very
very aware about the environment the
damaged human beings are doing to our
planet and it's all a byproduct of a you
know an insane consumer society that is
just literally destroying our planet
this whole idea of materialism consumed
by this by that have this have that you
know the same stuff I've been talking
about for years and my old sex drugs and
rock'n'roll talks so I think it's one of
the positive things is that people are
flying less people are driving less it's
like the atmosphere is clearing up
pollution is clearing up and hopefully
it's making human beings realize that
you know the people who are really
important are things like doctors and
nurses and people who you know check out
your shopping and people who deliver
food and people who grow food right I
mean you start to realize what's really
really important in life you know and
they're not like hedge fund managers and
billionaires and these people are not
really the ones who keep our world go be
at least on the everyday level you know
so yeah I mean these are just some of
the things you know
[Music]
there are things that worry me I won't
lie you know I worry about I'm very very
concerned about the infringement on
civil liberties literally what yesterday
or the day before yesterday the British
government passed a very very very
draconian far-reaching bill they
literally give
and dictatorial powers I mean they
literally could do it they they could
literally do what China does you know so
some of that is really scary it's scary
from a point of view if if there are
people who do have an agenda other than
just the concern of the nation's health
they could drive some really scary stuff
forward but you know you just you just
realize that broad this is Eddie this is
like what so many people on the planet
are living through this anyway you know
that for them mastered their everyday
life it doesn't make it mean that we
should you know I think in the in the
states you you know you know you have a
constitution things are a lot harder to
mess around with but still you know even
in the states it's been going on since
9/11 you know you've had a really
massive erosion of civil liberties and
basic rights that you know people have
taken for granted for decades and
decades did you see some of that smart
clear up they showed pictures before
yeah you've seen that I saw that yeah I
saw that in China massive smoke Lehrer
you know in Venice that canals clearing
up he's focused there's no boats
chatting up all the water just you know
like things like dolphins like people
have never seen before people hearing
birds singing in cities people say we
never heard the birds before it's like
simple things like that that um you know
though those are very very good things
so and you know spiritually as well I
think it's really good you know because
the things we we forget that the prophet
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam brought he
you know how he he actually told us to
stay in our homes like you know this is
one of the things Islam you know don't
see in the streets beware of seeing in
the streets no there's and this is not
just in times of fitna right it's a good
thing in Islam just to you know stay in
your home you know keep to yourself to
yourself
like you putting up there the hadith
yeah yeah I mean you know it's amazing
what the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam was saying bro 1400
years ago so like yeah you put this
hadith if you hear of an outbreak of
plague in a land do not enter it but if
the plague breaks out in a place where
you are in it do not leave that place so
how the prophet sallallaahu early he was
a 1,400 years ago was teaching us about
quarantine I mean one of the hadith
which I don't I don't
I've forgotten this hadith you know like
unless a Hadees sometimes actually
impacts on your life you may read it but
it just you know it doesn't register so
the Haditha people are mentioning about
the person who stays at home at the time
of plague they get the reward of a
martyr I mean subhanAllah bro I mean
we're not talking about people who died
of the plague we're talking about people
who stay at home they are patient they
put their trust in Allah they know that
whatever Allah has decreed for them is
gonna happen and you know they in that
state
they get the reward of subhanAllah Amato
so this is a this is a good thing this
is a very very good thing
what about ya now what comes to your
mind when you when you read this so we
covered the first hadith where it's
amazing 1400 years ago you had the last
and final messenger sent to mankind
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him he mentioned that the
quarantine yep
alright and then now this is really
because we started off with all the
affairs of the believer are good you
know you quoted that authentic prophetic
tradition otherone of I think optimism
what do you think when you hear this
that there is no disease except that the
crater of God Almighty Allah has sent a
cure and absolutely and it's hadith like
this that actually put Muslim
civilization at the forefront of
developing science and medicine and you
know all sorts of things that were
beneficial for Humanity because they
were motivated by these things by
looking for a cure for diseases so this
is again this is this is a very hopeful
statement and it's something that really
encourages us and makes us understand
that also it really makes us understand
a little bit about the purpose of life
right people you know I remember one
famous atheist he's a celebrity going on
TV once and ranting about oh there's
this illness and if there's a God you
know how does God let people die of this
illness and you know there he was and
he's actually a very very intelligent
guy and as he was saying that I was
thinking well if you care so much why
didn't you dedicate your life to finding
a cure for it instead of doing you know
pretty much pointless thing like being a
comedian and and the reality is the cure
is out there and life is a test you see
what are we gonna do with the
intelligence that was good at school but
what are we gonna do with the the brain
that Allah has given us at our
intelligence all our faculties or our
materialistic one of the things that you
know I saw a recent Loren booth posted
it and I reposted it on my Instagram was
you know like why are we spending all
this money on arms and weapons you know
this is one of the thing now we have the
I don't know the new head of the UN
saying look this is a real sign for
everybody why are we why are we fighting
each other why are we killing each other
you know this disease
you know this pandemic I think it's
really the first of its kind I saw I
suppose the panic the Spanish flu had a
similar effect in the sense that it was
worldwide the Black Death was I think as
far as I know the Black Death was more
concentrated in Europe but this is the
first time something has gone like quite
so global yeah and it does make us
realize that we are just one people we
breathe the same air right we the oceans
all our oceans are connected we are all
connected
you know this whole idea of
nation-states that we can divide
ourselves up into these nations and draw
borders and you know it's so outdated
you know it's it's really time we come
back to the Islamic understanding that
we are all day
Adam we're all descended for one man and
one woman real all family we are all
cousins we're all brothers and sisters
we all connected to each other you know
not just physically but you know in our
genetics and and even ultimately
spiritually you you mentioned a key word
now especially during these time of the
corona virus now dependable pandemic you
mentioned something real important and
this can be a means of people really
reflecting on those key word you said
purpose of life I want to get your
reaction to this excuse some of the
instruments here just us how the video
came but I want to get your reaction to
to this it goes back to what we're
talking about purpose and some of these
very important questions in life and
this is from I don't know if you
recognize this individual here sometimes
yeah Ben Affleck oh yeah I'm cool are
you ready to find some sort of sense of
meaning and purpose you know I was not
raised religious I don't I'm not a very
good Christian although I go to church
with my kids because it was important to
Jennifer and and now I go to and I like
it quite a bit I get depressed began to
depressants they're very helpful for me
I've taken themselves 26 years old
various different kinds I just wish to
try this and try that sometimes they
won't tell you about some awful side
effect two times in the last three years
he went to rehab always worried that his
drinking was affecting the children at
the center of his life I really don't
want my children to pay for myself
looking back at our 25 years during
interviews what have you learned about
yourself and women and what women
mm your methodist church kids are
baptized then I got introduced to
Christianity a little bit later in life
one of the things that I found most
beautiful about it and I'm not a you
know I struggled with my faith I
struggle with with belief but I do I do
see there's something enormous Lea
beautiful and elegant about the notion
that we are all sinners and that it's
that you know arts are job to to to find
our redemption to find God's love to
redeem ourselves so there the best life
that we can live to love one another to
not judge one another to forgive one
another I think those are extremely
powerful ideas and very very relevant
probably more relevant today than ever
because there's a little bit more of an
attitude of like find something somebody
did wrong once and yeah kind of get rid
of it and that to me feels unnecessarily
judgmental you know it's that that he
was not sin cast the first stone I think
is a very wise proverb I wouldn't start
off with what he first he he mentioned
because that goes in line with what you
were saying you know the purpose of life
he said he wants meaning purpose in life
that he wasn't raised a religious person
and really not a good Christian what
goes to your mind when you hear this
well you know like it's something I've
been saying for years and I think though
deep down inside why the reason why I
believe people are depressed one of the
most one of the major reasons why people
are depressed is exactly this they don't
know the purpose of life and the real
problem with Christianity for someone
like who's clearly very intelligent like
ben affleck comes across as being
someone who is obviously quite a smart
guy and you know it's interesting I'd
love to hear why in detail he struggles
with faith a lot of the time people
struggle with it because it makes it
makes sense to them on an emotional
level at some level it makes emotional
sense but it doesn't make it
electricians you know anyone any
intelligent person is going to struggle
with the concept of the Trinity the idea
of God becoming a man and dying on the
cross right even the whole Christian
story of salvation you know the idea
that God kills an innocent person for
everybody else's sins
you know like anyone who sits there
thinking about it just for a bit it's
gonna start thinking this is just man
right yet on the other hand like he says
Jesus says you know some really
beautiful stuff like really amazing
stuff like you read the Beatitudes for
example you know blessed are the meek
you know what they should and I always
think about that especially these days
you know blessed are the meek for they
shall inherit the earth
you know bless it all the peace with
peacemakers and you know they'll be cool
sons of God and blessed are the ones who
seek justice you know and so on and so
forth beautiful the actual teachings of
Jesus are really beautiful
it's the theology around him that is
just doesn't make any sense right and
people don't realize that you know
Christianity is not the religion of
Jesus it's a religion about Jesus so I
can see why you know at one hand he's
very attracted to it on another hand
he's from an intellectual level he's
probably really really confused and it's
not I suppose it's not gonna help him
some people I guess what they can do is
they can just put that aside they'll
just they'll come up with a sort of
rationalization religion doesn't need to
make sense I don't need to understand
why I believe in God or not they just
you know they put it which is fine to us
to an extent right but ultimately the
problem is is that in order to really
feel you know the purpose of life the
explanation for the purpose of life has
to make sense it has to make sense
intellectually and it has to make sense
deep down spiritually within yourself
and if it doesn't you're always gonna be
your was gonna be lost you're still
gonna be lost right that's often what I
say to Christians I don't I you know
when why well when I speak to Christians
I never deny them their experiences
right because for them many of
religion has changed their life and I
don't say all that's a liar so yeah I
mean it did because you found you found
something of the truth but you know now
you're talking to me and maybe some
bigger truth has come to you some deeper
truth is come to you right you have to
constantly assess that so yeah I mean
you know I feel for those guys I I think
the problem is as you know appreciate
Eddie you know very well right even if
people know even if people knew that
Islam was the truth
right even if we could get through to
Ben Affleck and or people like that and
have a conversation where they the
problem is you know you and you know
this very well as a as a guy very much
involved in our since I've known you
that Eddie the Dean show has always been
about reaching out to non-muslims
letting them know what the true message
of Islam you know may Allah bless you
all with the astounding work you've been
doing that you know how challenging it
is you know how many barriers how many
misconceptions that you're always trying
to break down and say listen guys you
know give us a chance
you know don't come here with all your
you know pre-programmed ideas of what
you think Islam and Muslims are about
we're not about that that's what you're
always saying right you're always saying
that but the crazy thing is that even if
we could get beyond that and we could
then get to explore even if they say
okay that makes sense
then they've got another challenge
another challenge is that Islam and
Muslims are demonized you have to have a
lot of courage to be a Muslim these days
to just be a Muslim even if you're born
into a Muslim family it takes courage to
convert to Islam it takes maybe even
more courage right it's a very big
courageous step but people need it so
badly you know so desperately the world
needs it you know so I you know I wish
the best book you know for that guy I
can so relate to what he's saying
actually you know I'm sure you and me
you know went through a very very
similar like experience like you know it
sounds so similar to the sort of
you know the sort of the same well I you
know the existential angst they call it
you know that that big questions that I
was asking myself you know and a lot
like I didn't you know I was young and I
had that strength and you know he I
don't know how old Ben Affleck is now
must be getting on a bit right yeah for
people that I don't know because you
came from a Christian background you
went through that struggle with your
family there's people can watch that
story it's all over we've interviewed
you before regarding your story if they
want to see that but do you think
there's also so you think there's a
direct correlation with him kind of
going through life not knowing the
purpose and then the antidepressants the
drugs they also the drinking he talks
about he he talks about how he would
just want to drink on occasion just like
everybody does but then it doesn't
happen like that you know he just you
get just deeper and deeper into it but
it's Lomb do you think because in
Christianity yeah you have verses that
clearly talk about you know why and
being a mocker you shouldn't drink you
know you even have many pastors who come
out but then there's also a debate like
oh this is the old law this is that and
the other so but you think been asking
him if he had these clear guidelines
like Islam is clear on it it's forbidden
there's no doubt about it where it's not
up in the air do you think Ben Askren
needs Islam needs that's that complete
submission to his his creator that he
has that purpose is lined out or many
people you know Christianity other ways
it's just kind of you know make up the
rules as you go change the goalposts
here and there to suit your desires I
think one of the things that Eddie that
you went and you talked to so many
converts to Islam hamdulillah one of the
things you will find consistently that
converts mentioned about one of the
things that they love about being a
Muslim is that you know you have very
clear boundaries yeah right yeah what
you're allowed to do and what you're not
allowed to do like 99% of the time it's
not confusing you don't need to oh
should I you know have a little sip of
wine
in the social setting you know like okay
some people they go to Alcoholics
Anonymous and you know they make it
clear to them they give them that you
know they give them that clear thing
like you're not allowed to drink that's
it you just can't drink no drink
day by day and take it day by day notice
it not a bit no nothing right but a lot
of people and it's not just with drink
it's with a whole lot of other things
yeah right how do you interact with
women you know so some people have a
problem with women right
you know they can't restrain themselves
right well you know it's man gives
simple rules you don't shake hands you
don't touch you don't kiss you don't you
don't have physical contact because
that's the word that's where it starts
and so it's whole it's so interesting
with this Harvey wine this wine stein
whatever his name was right and the
whole me to campaign and like how simple
would it be if people had the Islamic
rules right if someone is not your wife
or your mother or your sister or you
know like you don't have visible concept
with them you don't sit alone in a room
with them it's simple right the rules
are very very simple just all of the
rules the same with drinking not only
don't you drink it you don't touch it
you don't carry it you don't sell it you
know you don't sit in the same table
where people are drinking it right
that's how much you need to be away from
alcohol right so it gives these very
very clear rules that not only tells you
don't do the sin but just keep away from
even the things they're gonna lead you
to that sin right and it's all for the
benefit of human beings a lot doesn't
need us to you know not drink or not
whatever right a lot doesn't need us to
pray it's not like God gets stronger
because we pray to him right now this
guidance is there to help us and to make
our lives better right I mean that's not
to say that there aren't Muslims who
drink you know course there are you know
there are Muslims who drink and take
drugs and you know whatever but the
thing is the difference is that all of
those people still know what the
guidelines are you understand they know
it they know it's wrong right but the
real confusion is in life is when you
don't even know that's this
while with a glass of wine old so many
doctors say that it's actually healthy
for you right a glass of wine a day and
that type of stuff right and no in Islam
it says it doesn't matter even if
there's good in it even if there is so
even though Allah says there is good in
it but the evil is so much more than the
good you have to give it up altogether
right this is the principle right a
little bit of good in something does not
mean right that you are allowed that
thing right and it's the same the other
way around right it doesn't just mean
because there's a little bit of bad in
something that you just give it up
altogether right so yeah I mean is a
beautiful thing it's time gives you
those clear clear guidelines right it's
the same with everything how many times
should I pray to God a day or a week or
whatever right like yeah if you think
about it maybe you would spend your
whole life praying because God is
definitely deserving of it but you know
no Allah tells us pray five times a day
that's the minimum that you have to do
you know you take that space out five
times in a day it's just a few minutes
five times a day and you reconnect with
your Creator you know the rules are
clear right so with fasting so with
giving charity there's a minimum amount
of stuff you have to do it mm-hmm yeah
one other thing he said in his interview
he talked about one of the most
beautiful things along with his struggle
with faith that he's still going through
is this disbelief and notion that we're
all sinners and then it just reminds me
you know of the the Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him who has
many statements talking about that you
know we're all sinners and the best of
sinners are those who turn back to their
Creator not do not through a blood
sacrifice which many people you also
struggled with you talked about that in
your story but just connecting with the
one God the creator of the heavens and
earth Allah directly without any
intermediary and seeking forgiveness
absolutely Eddy you know you hit the
the head bro and you know it also
reminds you that you know the prophet
muhammad sallallahu alayhi wa sallam ii
he is saying the son of adam sins by
night and by day right that's everybody
everybody is gonna fall short the
problem here is that christianity you
know so we agree actually we agree that
you know everyone's gonna fall short
everyone's gonna commit sins right
the problem is Christianity comes with a
very convoluted path to allow you to
connect with God right through believing
that somehow God has to kill himself and
commit suicide or kill his son you know
even worse I don't know which is worse
of the two or makes less sense right you
know even would have for people to for
their sins to be forgiven and to be
reconnected with God but in Islam you
just have to repent like the beautiful
thing is you just recognize that yes I
am a needy weak human being I fell short
I committed a sin God forgive me right
and you say it sincerely you know you
know you've done wrong you ask Allah to
forgive you I think that thing that you
know the beautiful and Allah will
forgive you and I mean not only does all
not forgive you he gives you good deeds
nearly as great as the sins you
committed to replace it that is how
Allah loves repentance you know so that
there's that beautiful story
you know of the you know the story of
the prodigal son right the prodigal son
this is a biblical story the story of
Jesus talks about the prodigal son you
know the son that goes off and he just
he's a bad boy right and you know and he
comes home and when he comes home his
father is so so happy you know he saw as
a lamb for him it's in the best thing
you know because why because he's this
is that this is that this is the example
of repentance this is the example of
Toba how much Allah loves a person to
come back you know especially from being
in that bad situation but the other
thing that ben affleck you know
I think the other point that is really
key that he makes right it's when you
realize there's two things two points
actually when you realize that number
one everyone's a sinner right you know
you realize that ok I'm bad but everyone
does bad right because you know here's
human beings it's very important for us
to realize that you know I'm not just
the only one right so you know when
people go through a bad situation in
life and you know people I'm sure people
ask you for advice all the time Eddie
they ask me for advice all the time but
often people that telling me their story
and I say listen believe me you're not
the only one who's gone gone through
this right so many people this is I
wouldn't say it's normal but like lots
of people go through business like
really and it's like yeah really and
it's like wow I thought I was the only
one so this idea of thinking I'm just
the only one is sort of like makes you
think you're a whole lot worse than you
are right so when you realize that yeah
you know and by the way it's very
interesting cuz it's damaging
psychologically being yourself up right
what you've done doesn't help you it
actually ends most of the time it makes
you worse right that's the difference
right it doesn't mean you don't
acknowledge I'm wrong and you try and
change but that's the part you want to
take yeah what I did was wrong but I'm
human I've got weaknesses I sin like
everybody sins but you're gonna try and
change yourself and make yourself better
right it's actually easier to do it from
that perspective of realizing that yeah
we all commit sins on just a human and
the other thing is I think the other
thing you mentioned was soul mass is
just not being judgmental about people
right when you realize that everyone's a
sinner and you're a sinner right you
were a sinner I'm a sinner and you're a
sinner then you realize they're who you
to judge anybody else right you know
people sometimes say oh you know this
guy there's this guy this Muslim you
know he's got a big beard and he prays
and goes to the mosque and yeah he does
these bad things you know and your
religion tells tells you this maybe even
a Muslim saying this right your religion
tells you that prayer is supposed to
keep you away from fashion show
which means like fishes like open like
well you know Melanie yeah
cities sins and evil right so I say well
okay but it's it does because imagine
how bad that person would be if he
didn't pray right you know and the thing
is you know don't we have Eddie don't we
have enough human beings us don't you
have enough of our own sins to worry
about rather than spending our time
looking at everybody else and judging
everybody else so that was a really nice
thing being said is the he was reminding
us about don't judge on others don't
look down on others because honestly if
you just look in yourself you're gonna
find enough to occupy your time with by
looking at your own sins instead of
looking at the people sin and so on I
think you know a few of the things he
said were quiet deep reflections and as
you know like there's so much similarity
obviously between what he's saying or
what Stan believes it happened to be one
when we look at shaykh abdul rahim green
when we look at God's love I mean can
you translate your name well I'm ashamed
you know means the the well Abdul is
like a slave or the servant or the
worshipper right really apt comes from
servitude or being in a state of
submission and you know which is really
worship of God right and our Rahim is
one of the names of God it's it's one of
the most frequently mentioned names of
God al Rahman which is the most merciful
and al Rahim is the specifically
merciful
right so Rahim is a tackle you know so
there's the general mercy of God the
Rama which is ar-rahim is one of the
names of God this is a mercy that is for
every creature everybody everything but
there's a special type of mercy that
Allah has rahim that is a special extra
type of mercy that is for you know
mostly really there are heinous for the
believers it's for the you know the true
pious servants of Allah right
this is what some scholars explain the
difference between al-rahman which is
the the general mercy of God this for
everyone and everything and ar-rahim
which is a very specific type of mercy
you know that is you know for the
believers so but god is the most
merciful you know this is the names of
god and he is alwa dude is the loving
and he is allah father he's the
forgiving you know and many many other
beautiful names that Allah has to remind
of verses forgiveness as mercy as
kindness is beneficial to humanity so in
every actually so if Ben was to get this
message and then and other people like
him to really hear these qualities that
are all there in Islam and then some of
the things that they've been confused
about the Trinity you know the one
sacrifice of Jesus and here now just
defining the Creator God Almighty a laws
name of the most loving the most
merciful that they can go directly to
the creator beg for his mercy and he
will forgive them is that that works
absolutely you know like for someone
like he's a smart guy right but for
anybody I would just you know most
people they never think you know they
may search through every religion every
philosophy they look everywhere but for
some reason they'll never look at Islam
even though it's one of the biggest and
greatest religions on earth people
people will you know they was so my
advice to him and anyone is pick up a
Koran right pick up a translation of the
Quran and read it you know and ask God
for guidance to show you that's all that
we can say you know take on the book and
read it and think about it you know this
is what I recommend everybody do pick up
a book or an a translation of the Quran
and you know there's a nice new
occurring what it's called at this
there's a nice new one that's been done
new translation is like easy to read
clear clear Quran
sorry international and yeah the clear
coat yeah so you know al hamdulillah you
know you can find something like the
Quran which
you know translated into a more
accessible language right read it and
see and I I think you'll people will
find I'm sure I don't think I'm sure
that they'll find the answers to the
questions they have they'll find that
they'll find what they're looking for as
long as they're approached it with
sincerity and an open heart they'll find
it you know at the end of his interview
he mentioned a story of Esau a salam
jesus peace be upon him who we love is
one of the greatest messengers that God
Almighty Allah ever sent who came with
the same message as all the other
messengers worship the Creator not the
creation be morally upright do good
deeds and that's how you can get
paradise God's mercy
he said cast the first stone and had me
thinking because I just interviewed a
former Christian minister of 40 years
Richard and he was also a Christian
professor and this was one of the things
that when when for all these years he
thought that he mentions I believe this
story not being in the one of those that
were not authentic Thai was out that's
wrong and this story and then along with
the Matthew Mark Luke and John you know
those books just because they had the
name of the author's but they really
were anonymous books so it just had you
know because most people ninety-nine
percent of the people out there so what
do you think now this the also that when
when you went through this the
authenticity of the crowd versus you
know other other books and scriptures
yeah I mean you know I think it's really
really I mean that's one of the
outstanding things about the Quran is
the way that the Quran has been
preserved and that's always a question
that anyone who starts to delve deeper
and look into this issue comes across
this problem right like he it's very
hard to really feel genuinely convinced
I don't know and let's look people there
are always people who want to convince
themselves and make themselves believe
what they want to believe
right which is fine to a certain extent
right you can't be totally skeptical
about everything you have to have some
level of trust right but I think that
all
when you look at the Bible when you look
at the Gospels and especially in the
Gospels they're really really
problematic there's no real scientific
way that we can say this is what Jesus
really said that there's no even there's
no really reliable process like even if
they found ancient documents the problem
is they're just some Gospels out of so
many other Gospels and sure of saying
well we just believe that God made sure
that those are the ones that are
preserved because they were the best
ones which I sort of get that I can get
that as a sort of you know I can get it
as a faith based argument that well God
must have preserved this word because
it's God word so what we've got must be
like the thing but that but that's just
a belief right there's no way to support
that historically or scientifically
there's no way to really assess from an
independent objective point of view that
Matthew Mark Luke and John is actually
what Jesus really really said there's
just no way to do that so yeah you can
take it from a point of your faith but I
mean that's that's what goes back to
what I was saying about Ben afleck for
people who are very intelligent who have
a rational approach in a society we've
been taught to question things we want
to make sure things and it's good we
want to make sure things are authentic I
think that the beautiful thing about
Islam another beautiful thing about them
is that when you study the preservation
of the Quran when you study the
preservation of the hadith when you go
deep into studying the preservation of
the authentic sayings of the Prophet you
come across a truly remarkable system
there is a scientific system so that's
the thing doesn't depend upon faith
right you could be a historian and just
come from the point of view of you know
objective historical perspective and
you'd still be pretty sure that yep the
Quran is pretty much what Muhammad
said right those hadith are pretty
reliable we could depend upon them as
sources of information right I don't
think you can do that with the gospel
not really you know but with the Bible's
especially the New Testaments so it is
really really problematic yeah and the
example that you mentioned of the you
know the stoning of the adulterous woman
you know let me let the woman who didn't
sin cast the first stone as you
mentioned the oldest complete biblical
manuscript is the codex sinaiticus which
was found on the st. catherine's
monastery in sinai it doesn't have it in
it that that passage is not there it's
quite interesting goodness by Constantin
Tischendorf spent his life searching for
the oldest complete Bible biblical
manuscript you know I think the 18th
century minds in the century he found it
in the sinai & st. katherine's monastery
it didn't have he was missing in fact it
was missing considerable numbers of
verses and texts and even I think you
had an extra epistle that wasn't and so
even it was important the same Bible
really as the ones that Christians have
today so this is a whole dispute again
it doesn't really give you a lot of
confidence does it to say oh this is
really God's Word where as we do have
that confidence when it comes to the
Quran yeah what is Islam what's unique
about Islam from other man-made
religions how would you explain it to
been in in a minute
like what stands out what is the most
important thing in Islam and what is the
most beautiful thing about its time the
standout point about Islam is its what
it teaches about God what it teaches
about God is so in tune with both your
nature what you believe inside yourself
and also your intellect and that is the
beautiful thing that the way the Quran
talks about God it's like that makes
sense it makes so much
and that's what you will do you'll find
God you really find who is dog because
that ultimately that's always the
purpose of life the purpose of life is
to know to know God right so that's what
you're gonna find a very very beautiful
concept that God is unique God is one
God is not like anything in this
universe and nothing in this universe is
like good if that is the standout point
that pure monotheism that's that's
really what is you can you can see where
people attack Islam on many different
things but when you sit with them you
put things in context light bulb goes on
say oh that makes sense I didn't think
about it like that
but you don't really see people
attacking Islam submission to the
Creator not to creation under theology
on the pure monotheism do you have you
in all your years oh and and you see
this is the thing this is very
interesting when you look at someone
right which we look at some of my
Dawkins right you look at his path of
attacking religions when he attacks
Christianity he attacks it from the
point of view as the obvious theology
but he doesn't do that with this land
right with this lamb you'll talk about a
lot of the time I will talk about stuff
that's not Islam anyway old suicide
bombing right well you know modern Islam
allows it anyway but you know you
understand so he talks about these
things terrorism you know the way women
are treated like the normal you know
your normal misconceptions to be honest
right so he can't really attack it's
then from a point of view of his
theology because his theology is so
solid it's really really hard to argue
against and this is something you find
fight pretty consistently right and of
course the people who would attack
Islamist theology or Christians or they
take again when they do that from the
point of their belief system right not
that their theology makes any sense at
all it's just something that they
presumed that you know like so one is
with fellow Christian believers they can
presume eternity they can presume that
God II you know that Jesus is God
incarnate these the son of God and this
and that right oh you know those Muslims
don't believe that
yeah handle thanks to God we don't
believe that because
contradicts true monotheism but you know
from from the outside know you'll find
is very very hard to attack is you know
it stands theology so when they do
attack it often it's it's not even from
the point of view of the things that
Islam actually believes you know that's
another interesting thing you know
because often especially when it comes
from the point of view of a Christian
when Christians are attacking women's
rights in Islam well did you read what
the Bible said about women right when
they talk about punishments
have you read the punishments in the
Bible when it talks about you know Jihad
have you read about warfare and how the
Bible talks about you know waging war
right have you read these things because
it's worse from a biblical perspective
than it is from a Quranic perspective so
like if that's your criterion for saying
Islam is not true then your own religion
is even more not true that's the problem
you're gonna be faced with so yeah you
know it doesn't mean you know you know
listen not everything is time teachers
is gonna be what you like and of course
it's not right because islam is not
revealed to follow your desires islam
was revealed in fact the opposite for
you to resist your desires resist your
impulses so you may not like everything
it says right i may not like the taste
of a certain medicine right but no it's
the cure for my illness right you may
not like getting up in the morning and
stretching and taking exercises right
and taking a cold shower which is so
good for you right but oh my that is
that stuff is good for you you know it's
gonna give you life and make you
stronger so this is something we know
not everything you love is good for you
and not everything you hate is bad to
you you know so to make it a criterion
of judgment oh I don't like this thing
that the Quran says that's not a very
good system of judging whether something
is true or not going back just wrapping
up in our in our last closing going back
to the
pandemic that we're dealing with now the
corona virus you hear and you see so
many things so many questions you you
you mentioned one about one number one
thing is just staying optimistic you
quoted the hadith you know the all of
the affairs that believe are good so you
know we look for the good in things but
how can how can a Muslim was conscious
of his creator and the realities around
us that you do have satanic forces right
you you have deception how do you keep a
balance and how do you implement the
quranic ayah where god almighty is
talking about verifying checking things
up you know if an untrue you know
trustworthy person allah faucet comes to
you how do you yourself and what do you
what do you see is the best balance
where you're not going to one extreme or
the other but at the same time people
who are giving you things you know this
is a reality it's going on but you know
like other things that are kind of slid
under the carpet now like you said you
know for instance giving you examples
people who have spread lies and weapons
of mass destruction right and they've
gotten the whole world to come along
babies and incubators you know that one
you remember that one yeah yeah yeah do
you know about the half a million that
was spent on fake terrorist videos do
you know about that yeah yeah i you know
about the whole thing with the world
being confused or some blinded to the
fact that what's going on in in the
open-air prison right yeah so you got
lie after lie after lie after lie i was
a CI director we lied we cheated we
steal stole that's like we had with
entire we had entire training courses
but the media seems like it's magic it
works magic on people the mainstream
media so how do you balance it out
where can you go to verify to check so
you're not being as they say hood
wingless Li you know honestly the thing
is bro is that you have to realize that
people who are not like people who are
not clearly guided by Allah's guidance
after guidance there is nothing except
going astray you know you have to
realize that right outside of guidance
there's nothing except going astray and
it doesn't even look people don't even
have to be malicious they don't even
have to be nasty like people you can
know this from your own life any convert
can tell you it's like it's not that you
don't love your parents you love your
parents but if your parents are not
Muslim right your parents are not going
to be guiding you by the wisdom of the
Quran and the Sunnah they're going to be
guiding you by what they think is
important in life so my mom is always
asking oh I hope they're paying you for
giving these talks right I hope that and
it's like well it's not about being paid
mom you know this is something you do
for Allah right you know like but what's
the point in me telling her that stuff I
just say yeah yeah you know don't worry
that pain even though sometimes they
don't even pay my ticket you know but I
mean sometimes people do right they give
you something they help you right but
the point is is that do you understand
what I'm trying to say it is that like
your mum loves you she cares about you
but she's not guiding you with all those
guidance right I remember one chef now
this is to give you a this is to give
you a counter example and I don't worry
I'm coming to what you might you'll see
where I'm coming from in a second yeah
I'll give you a counter example right a
chef I there's one chef very nice [ __ ]
his mother used to advise him oh my son
I'm not worried for you about this and
that you know what I'm worried for you
when you go and you give your talks and
lectures and worried you about you
showing off I'm worried that you will do
things not sincerely for the sake of
Allah and all of this effort and all of
this time you put into it
it will ruin you because you didn't do
it with floss all my son have it floss
you see that the
once between this mother advising her
son right and you know the Muslim mother
advising her son and so it's the same
with our governments right I don't think
that most governments want bad for their
people right I don't think that I
actually genuinely think most
governments do want good for their
people right but how do they define
what's good for their people right so in
America you know they believe in
capitalism that's what they believe in
they believe that's the system they
believe that ultimately capitalism is
what they think is gonna bring about a
good Society because they think it's
gonna make people wealthier and they
think that that's what's important in
life that money is you know the economy
is more important than people's lives
because there's a reason for that
because they think that money is what
makes you happy in the end is what's
gonna make you successful but that's all
a lie right I'm not saying that lying on
purpose it's just they believe in a lie
it's not true that money makes you happy
right and we know that as a spiritual
truth so the thing is we have to
understand that is that even if our
governments are not mission malicious
and vicious right even if they weren't
good for us the good they want for us is
not correct according to Allah's
guidance let alone we answer that that
people are also misguided by Shaitaan
let alone we add to that that note there
are some people who are really genuinely
evil and unfortunately some people maybe
they don't even care they don't even
care they're just in it for themselves
they don't care about people they don't
care about society or maybe even worse
on a crazy extreme is that some people
actually say this and they just like
seeing people suffer there are people
who are genuinely like that and we've
seen in history there are rulers and
there are tyrants and you know we
genuinely seem to enjoy making their
people suffer so you have that whole
spectrum it would be silly of us a naive
of us right not to be aware of that but
at the end of the day what can we do
right at the end of the day what can we
do is we can be good Muslims we can say
our prayers we can
fast we can do whatever we can to enjoin
what is right and forbid what is wrong
right so we have to realize that look
our options are limited there is not
much point you spending too much time
with conspiracy theories that may or may
not be true maybe some of those
conspiracies theories are actually true
but what are you gonna do about it
practically what you can do about it
actually is read the Quran say your
prayers make dhikr of Allah invite
people to Islam invite people to lay
hila hit the log put your trust in Allah
right because the courage they plotted
in the planned and they planned and
planned but the prophet sallallaahu Ali
what did the Prophet do he invited them
today in the law and you know when the
time was they came to try and kill him
Allah told him and Allah saved him and
Allah rescued him right and Allah took a
buckler and the Prophet and they were in
the famous incident when they were in
the cave hiding a prophet the Messenger
of God
the Messenger of God was hiding in a
cave yaxha run away and hide well that's
what he had to do right when the time
came but I loved protected him so what
that's what can you do you can do only
what's in front of your face right and
don't worry too much and don't stress
too much about other stuff because it's
just with unlock right all you can do is
the best with what you've got what comes
to you and that's it I don't know don't
stress out too much that's the thing I
trust in Allah husband along one
molecule you know Allah you know we rely
upon him and he's the best of guardians
yeah I like what you said so we have the
day plot and plan a lot plans allows the
best of planners you have the car that's
that so things that are out of your
control because you hear a lot of things
set out there but is it synthetic is it
man-made is that this are they you know
global is you hear all sorts of things
being porn out there but that's out of
your control but the things that are in
your control people talk about
pharmaceutical company all these you've
heard a lot of the things that are out
there now you say something's might be
true am I not whatever is out of our
control but one thing is that in Arkin
is our connection with our Creator
strengthening that because you know we
gonna die tomorrow or the next day it
can happen so be ready for that but
another thing that really comes to mind
is taking care because you also hear
that again if it's meant to happen it's
meant to be but we dig the trench we tie
the camel our health you know we hear a
lot of people getting sick because of
the the immune system being compromised
genetically modified foods and the
environment and bad food bad water and
all these things I mean we see a lot a
lot of people who don't take their
health serious I mean you're someone who
bike rides you work out you you you eat
good how important is that and our Dean
you know really taking the Imana that
Allah Samantha's given our body and not
just putting as the saying it says you
know Allah didn't create this body as
the garbage can don't put garbage in it
absolutely and I agree with that bro and
you do your best like you know I look
there's lots of things that I am I'll be
honest as their stuff that I am
extremely concerned about I'm concerned
about a world where pharmaceutical
companies can manufacture diseases for
which they are the only ones who have
manufactured a cure right it is
absolutely crazy and perhaps this is a
reason why there should not be any
private pharmaceutical companies they
shouldn't exist they should all be
controlled like by governments so there
is a minimum you know money-making
agenda there there's something very
uncomfortable about that right you know
that the whole idea that you know you
could be given a vaccine and you know
the vaccine itself may cause worse
diseases than the one that it's trying
to prevent it's not that I don't believe
in the effectiveness of bactine vaccines
as a scientific principle I believe in
it but the problem is what you mentioned
I'm sorry as someone said right someone
sent me someone sent this I had this I
had it's just what it since you said
vaccines I don't know what your what you
think about this do you see this yeah
yeah I mean you know I look at the end
of the day if they make us take a
vaccine and they force us what can we do
yeah and
and it's not that I wouldn't get
vaccinated but it's like I have a right
I would think to research and think
carefully about what is being put into
my body and why right do I trust
everything I mean I avoid medication as
much as possible to be generally I avoid
it right but on the other hand and you
began with you know for every disease
there is a cure so you know there is
this trust factor there are serious
questions to be asked you know and we
know historically there have been
medications that have caused real real
problems right
so we know that historically so yeah
look these things concern me so and I'm
looking after your health is very very
important understand you know it's one
of the things the Prophet said the two
feet of sort of the son of Adam will not
move from their place in front of their
Lord until they are asked about five
things so your life and what you did
with it your health and how you cared
for it your money you know how you spent
it and how you how you earned it and how
you spent it so there's two things how
you earn your money and how you spent it
and your knowledge and how you acted on
it so like that's a whole lecture we
could give on that that hadith along but
one of the things the Prophet mentions
is your health right how did you care
for your health so you know keeping
healthy you know a modicum of good
physical exercise is the Sunnah of the
Prophet had a very very healthy life
mostly making sure you eat good hello
it's not just about food being a hat out
it's about food being taken treasure yes
yes yes yes so like you know I try to
eat as much stuff that I can that is
organic as possible home-cooked food as
much as possible right you know try to
avoid too much for the fine stuff
there's just basic things really like
it's not it's not really rocket science
being healthy right we usually have a
slogan eat real food
avoid faithfully there
I have quite a you know I'm not entirely
happy with the whole philosophy of
Western medicine right because when you
start studying about how most medication
works it actually works by poisoning
your body it works by disrupting the
systems in your body and how does it
disrupt the systems in your body by
poisoning your body right like through
levels of toxicity toxicity so I was
watching what's his name Trevor you know
this comedian guy he does that you know
that then he makes fun of the news car
is named Trevor something right but he's
a black guy from South Africa originally
right States so he was interviewing some
top guy from the White House and he was
admitting that all like vaccines have a
level of toxicity in it right and you
have to be careful about that
so like but this is the case with all
medication any medication you take right
it's all about poisoning your body right
it's just that the poison is supposed to
be helping some symptoms because that's
what it does it it disrupts the chemical
you know the chemical pathways in your
body to try and you know alleviate the
symptoms of particular diseases right so
I think we have to be very very careful
about what stuff we take anyway right
you look at chemotherapy chemotherapy is
literally killing you it's literally
killing yourself horrific thing right so
I don't know yeah you know I don't claim
to have any great medical knowledge and
it's not that I would not ever take
medicine I do take medicine I mean I for
example I suffer occasionally from like
really bad migraines and I found that
ibuprofen
you know the Bible proofing it's been a
lifesaver for me right it's helped me so
much you know I hunt alone I take you
say I'm do love this bug but it's like
really oats me but you know like I would
be careful not to take it unless I
really really have to because I just
fundamentally think that you don't put
this stuff in your body unless you
really really need to do it
over time you you have other other
problems that will arise the lining in
the stomach you will end up having you
know other issues that will come up was
ulcers it has problems with yes it does
so you know you have to be careful right
yeah you know just we have a saying it's
powerful says eat real food
avoid fake food you know because in the
food her pocket tease had a statement he
said let food be your medicine medicine
be your food so nowadays we follow the
food being modified refined a lot of
those nutritional qualities that are in
the foods that are meant to heal the
body repair the body a lot of times that
we're deplete of that and that that's
really that since we're you see how the
food that Allah the creator of heavens
and earth can have such a healing
empowering effect but many of us are
eating fake food and this is why I think
system too much too much this is that
actually most diseases come from the
stomach yes from eating too much that's
another problem yeah so really in
reality the you know and I can't say I
practice this myself very well but right
we should really just be eating enough
to keep us alive that's the amount of to
be should be taking in and then when we
do eat that food should be quality stuff
yeah if we we really if we live like
that we would suffer very very she
disease I think receive you know what
happens is why people because there's
these addictive elements in the food the
MSG and other things the sugar so now
you're not getting the nutritional
benefits and you just keep your body's
not satisfied because it's not nourished
and you just keep eating more and more
but when you eat right bad so you
believe this yeah so am I really
totally ROI I believe that's exactly
what happens your body is quite simple
in the sense that it's just like if it
doesn't have the nutrients it needs it
cells sends that signal you know and the
signal is I'm hungry yes yes if you
eating the same stuff that is actually
draining like so these refined foods
actually drain your body of nutrients in
it takes up vital nutrients in order to
digest it so you think are more depraved
then you feel more hungry you feel that
more hunger and you're never satiated
the more you eat the worse it gets or
you eat more and more and more and like
so that's the difference when you eat
really good healthy stuff right that
satisfies you because it has those
nutrients in it that in part is what
helps you deal with the hunger because
your body is not sending out those
signals it's like yeah I've got what I
need down yeah I know you mentioned will
wrap up but I you mentioned cold showers
and you've had have you heard because
it's about life hacks you find these
different things yeah you put your cell
phone I mean it's very interesting I'm
really into I'm looking into wim HOF at
the moment and his whole method I've
actually started his online course yeah
it's really interesting because there
are all of the stuff that he's you know
talking about I've been doing I realize
I've been doing some of that stuff since
I was a kid just myself I don't even
know why I was doing it right so but
yeah taking cold showers
breathing learning to breathe properly
like I I don't know it's just something
we just again I I started doing that
because I started getting into Buddhism
and yoga and stuff when I was before I
was Muslim right so I learned a lot
about breathing but simple things about
breathing correctly cold showers soul
good for you invigorating your body even
better if you could have a sauna and
cold showers like not everyone can I
have a sword right but you know that's
sort of stuff I've always loved that
stuff right I mean just today and you
know I told you because you were trying
to make this school with me I said I'm
gonna go with the kids for I took the
kids we went out for two hour walk so
just up in the hills where I live
there's a reservoir right and you can
imagine I think it's about you know
seven or eight degrees so this reservoir
is probably just freezing just about you
know zero maybe one or two degrees so I
just went for swimming that today that
was like so it'd be great you know so
yeah I really recommend that stuff that
is just gives so much energy you know it
gives you so much energy you have a cold
shower in the morning bull you know
you're really salad for the day you know
well yeah really invigorates and gets
the blood flowing and yeah so I'm I
definitely am into these things that's
really nice to see thinking martial arts
you know the I know you're a big guy in
the you know Brazilian jiu-jitsu circles
right so you know anything like that
very very good stuff oh that's nice I
bet I've been doing this via the win
half I've been in for a few years now 38
resets inhale let it go holes it yeah
then the cold showers really really it's
in it's an interesting like you put
yourself in an uncomfortable situation
for benefits yes yes I relate that back
into the Dean sometimes something might
be uncomfortable but it's free it's for
you better absolutely bro it's a very
Islamic principle yeah right and to be
believe me as I was walking up there I
knew that was gonna be cold and like my
whole you know I was saying you know
there's no way I'm cold walking up there
and they're not getting in the water you
know but I said to myself to myself you
know I like pushing myself out of my
comfort zone if I'm not feeling cut if
I'm feeling uncomfortable about it it's
like good right because you need to move
out of that comfort zone
stop feeling comfortable with yourself
and put yourself in something that is
you know a little bit uncomfortable and
it's good feel right and I think it's
lamb this is a you know you're right you
take it back to its land but everything
you like you know not everything that
you hate it it's bad to you you know
some things you don't like them but
they're good for you and we do them
because they're good for us and they
transform us and they build us and they
make us better and stronger people
whether it's spiritually mentally or
physically you know so that's it let's
look at this coronavirus situation this
lockdown let's look at it like that yeah
for a lot of people is uncomfortable but
you know we can get so many benefits
from it in sha allah look for the
benefits you know and Hum Dil Oh a
little bless all of us inshaallah and
inshallah we can out we had some plans
to meet up in bosnia didn't go through
but inshallah we get through this our
next meeting can be hopefully inshallah
god willing and i'd love to do that i'm
we should plan it inshaallah
finally properly so i i hopefully I will
maybe I'm do a sort of trip through
Europe and you know end up there and
show
and come back it'll be nice it'll be
beautiful in genre it was a nice we
covered a lot of good things a lot of
good points in Charlotte that can be a
benefit really nice made Allah the
creator that has an earth keep you and
your family and I mean and everyone's
safe
yeah I mean Eddie and yours as well my
dear brother and yours as well thank you
very much for your time Eddie it's great
to talk to you my brother
you take care inshallah all right so now
came to my Salaam alaikum alaikum where
the kids